i recently finished uh trying the
federal litigation in charlottesville
virginia we sued the organizers of the
charlottesville rally uh the white
supremacists who came down to
charlottesville and basically
wreaked havoc on the town ultimately
culminating in a
terror attack where james fields drove
his dodge challenger through a crowd of
29 or so counter-protesters killing
heather heyer and injuring a number of
folks including our clients and so we
took him to trial violence has been a
tactic for white supremacists since you
know the 1860s the klan started you know
they were committing
violent acts against
black people for the purpose of hurting
black people purpose of terrorizing the
community
voter suppression voter suppression for
the purpose of establishing dominance
violence has been a
um a key part of white supremacist
culture for 150 years and so
what a lot of white supremacists
including our defendants talked about is
that they want to spark a race war they
want to and there were folks that went
to charlottesville hoping that this was
it this was the beginning of the race
war
[Music]
you